That's my favorite line in that whole song [we] don't have to go out. This is so true right now
Hi guys, this is what I look like my name is Grace Helbig you do not know now. You know I?
Threw some foundation on my face, and that's it because I've been under the weather
[I've] been a little out of commission on Social Media and also just like
Normal health wise which I apologize for maybe this video will make up for it because I haven't been feeling well
I'm watching a lot of YouTube videos
Okay, I had to readjust my xP because I felt just really inferior
I teach you in film school on that when you want a character to feel inferior
You shoot a down angle when you want a character to feel
Fear you shoot [an] up angle Superior. That's the word
I was looking for I didn't go to English college so with not feeling [very] well
[I] have one watched a few drag queen makeup tutorials because I did one on this channel a few weeks ago
And it was really fun to do and I just I'm obsessed with the artistry that is drag makeup and - I learned that
Tomorrow July 14th is national hot dog day the internet says that the [national] hot dog and sausage
Council in the USA
Yeah, goose, you can dry [and] pretend
you sometimes wipe your butt across my whole backyard you cannot fall other people for having hobbies like being part of the
National hot dog and sausage that's right the national hot dog and sausage Council has declared july 14 national hot dog day
[so] I have I make a video combining these two things that I've exposed myself to over the last few days
and I'm gonna do some sort of drag makeup look inspired by and in preparation for
National hot dog day I went to CVS, and I bought a ton of makeup
[I] have expectations for myself that are higher than [they] should be but I just I think I can do this so let's
Do this [I] don't really tell you exactly what I hope the outcome is
I just want you to experience this moment of breathing a hot dog inspired drag look
Together because that's what eating a hot dog is all about right?
You don't know what's gonna happen after but it's always better to like you get it with other people, [okay] great
first thing I'm gonna do [is] I'm gonna actually glue my eyebrows down and I have to tell you guys by watching a bunch of
Drag queen makeup tutorials
[I] mean
I watched half of one and then decided I wanted to make makeup that [looked] like [a] hot dog and
I went to the store. I actually don't know at all
I'm doing I've heard that you can just glue down your eyebrows with a glue stick. So I have this elmer's Craft Bond
[uh-oh] is just a craft glue stick. Oh it's extra strength crap. This is a crafting glue stick this isn't just a normal blue stick
Okay, well you know
Do I do that? I don't know that seems like something makeup people do when they put something on their face
They go like this. I'm gonna put some [eyeshadow] face over my eyebrows just to see what happens, [woah]
National hot dog day here. We come hot and all so now let's put more
Foundation on let's just put it all on our face. You're just going to start slapping foundation all over this face this looks great
Hey, hot [dog]. I didn't do these eyebrows right this crap blue sucks a huge d. [oh]
Okay, gonna blend this [oh]
Wow
And also wow okay? Wow [they] always sit the makeup with powder, so let's set the makeup with powder. Here's a brush look I'm setting
Now we're going to start carving out our cheeks. Oh
God you're going to use this Kat von D shade and light palette and Kat Von D
I am so sorry for deeply. Deeply misusing your product right now here. We go. Let's try it
Yes that seems right? [oh], we're doing it. We are doing it
You know it's a good brush that you just bought when all the bristles keep coming off
On your face. [oh], no. Oh no, okay?
This feels like it's going to be offensive to the drag community and the [hot-dog-eating] community
And I'm just I'm sorry. We're gonna work on our eyes
We're going to try and make our eyes [look] like hot dogs [so] basically I want it to be want to close my [eyes]
There's hot dogs
[there's] every time I close my [eyes] anyway. There's hot [dogs] [in] there in my brain make it closer to you
So that you can really see how terrifying this looks. I bought this red rouge lip pencil from
Company probably is like please don't say our name
Please don't say our name nyx nyx nyx nyx remember that dating game show next on MTV
You don't you're so young
but if you do remember wow how degrading right says the girl that's about to draw hot dogs on our islands as a form of
Occupation is a lip liner, but we're gonna draw some hot dogs and see what happens, okay?
My milkshake brings all the boys to the yard, and they're like okay wow
There's third one wiener [there's] one wiener the hardest part about the hot dog drag queen tutorial is
matching your wieners
Not milkshake brings all the boys to God and oh look at that look at that
That's not the worst
But like I really hope no one ever knocks on my door right now because that would be the worst that I could be at
Coachella, I thought being a sia music video if you're like [me] tilda Swinton
There's just like this is a lot of look happening
so because I want to really make a stand out and make [it] more of a
Cartoonish feel I'm Gonna take some black Liquid liner and just
Outline weiniger saw my eyes tell me a beauty guru that's ever said that haha
Wow, that looks like actually fierce
Also, I don't know what the definition of Fierce
Actually is shake brings all the boys to go wish you guys could see that
This is how I'm holding my body when I put liquid liner off
Shake Brings boys the God and allah I just feel wild and free you can't have a winner without some funds hun
So let's add a hot dog bun to these wieners first. I'm gonna find some brown eyeshadow
I'm gonna try and draw some buns around the hotdogs wieners and [all] my eyes let's do it
I'm gonna take this like matte brown color. It's just any of them. I don't know a combo of all of them
Maybe touch this okay?
touch this
Okay, so my dog is barking at
Kids next door. I'm [just] pretending that it's not happening because I
Have like business to do and we can all agree this sucks a huge wiener right. This is just our base
I'm no artist. This is just our base and now I'm going to use this photo what the action
Right now I'm going to use this revlon
Metallic thing and see what happens, okay touch this, okay?
[touch] this [alright], so I'm gonna let this [dry] [for] a second. [oh] my God. I've been doing oh my God. I'm doing it
I'm doing beauty guru thing and now I'm Gonna use my black liquid eyeliner again to
Even you think that you should not be a part of this
Oh, use my gel liner have a gel liner [on] [it's] better than this area. We're gonna use this gel liner instead
He's feel like it's Gonna have more of an impact. That's a fuckin hot
wait
Wait wait and all the way that someone order wieners touch this
Is it very clearly hot dogs and any of you that hate my artistry?
But I'm gonna drag it up a little bit, and I'm gonna add some fake lashes
We're going to figure it out. Wow that does not look like it did before so you may be wondering like grace
What do you do with your lips?
I'm gonna make another [hot] dog or I take this red. We're gonna fill in the lips
[oh] this looks good family [if] you're watching this this is one of the ones you [don't] want to show that people
Do I have oh oh?
This is terrifying welcome to your new nightmares
[I] got this weird yellow eye shadow thing that I want to see if it works like mustard oh my God
Oh my [God]
It's a hot dog with [mustard] okay. I think that I'm done aka
I think I should stop doing this right now. There you go
There is my drag queen inspired no does not try quit inspired this
Ruins the credibility and talent of every drag queen [this] is not Drag queen inspired
I thought it might be but it's not this is my national hot dog inspired makeup look
Ready here. We go get the full effect
Wow, what the actual?
I hope you guys have a wonderful national hot dog day
I will probably later in the week be making corn dogs because I've never done that before
Either I even love hot dogs that much I just think they are the funniest food
Go-gurt is the dumbest food like in the dumb bad dumb way, and hot dogs are just the most hilarious
They're just like the crisp Barley of poop and so this is my homage
thanks for watching this video if you guys [enjoyed] this national hot dog big makeup tutorial please [subscribe] to this YouTube channel because
This is innovative content. [I] don't know
I'm sorry mom. I'm sorry dad. I'm sorry am I sorry [no], this is art
I decided I'm not sorry
I'm a little sorry